il ya une vidéo qui est sorti mais c'est
beaucoup d'événements il ya tous les
jours les gens qui venaient enfin mes
parents qui m'appelle ampleur pas ce qui
est des nouveaux événements ils me le
disent plus parce que si on avait
entendu votre maman en pleurs
il ya plusieurs fois des gens qui sont
venus cagoulé armé chez mes parents
c'était enfin moi je le sais ces fleurs
fois arrivé il ya plusieurs fois des
voitures qui font la ronde je reçois des
gens qui viennent devant les
explications des parents enfin oui ça
arrive tous les jours
j'ai appelé le commissariat de la ville
dans laquelle ils sont j'ai demandé un
soir parce que les lui fallait puisque
c'est à seulement à moi qui répondait
pas aux avocats par des parents ils
veulent bien faire j'étais un peu
désemparé j'ai vu que mes parents
n'étaient pas en sécurité donc j'ai je
les ai contactés il ya une voiture de la
bac qui était pendant une nuit c'est
tout alors regardez on a la vidéo des
menaces domicile de votre mère regarde
si on revient à trois là vous croyez
quoi vous
je ne joue pas de problème
et j'aimerais juste savoir où vous
attendent aux aides publiques de lui
en ce moment difficile tout ça
alors benjamin on a vu cette vidéo
aujourd'hui quand vous avez fait vos
excuses dans l'église est ce que pour
vous c'était une nouvelle provocation
bien c'est pas des excuses des excuses
c'est très ironique je sais ça je le
fais parce que c'est ce que tous on
attend de moi mais c'est pas des excuses
enfin fait comme ça le serait c'est
parce que déplacer mais aujourd'hui
quand vous voyez tout ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce que j'ai envie
de dire c'est que je suis venu
aujourd'hui seuls ouais pour être
sincère le plus honnête et le plus
indépendant possible
et je veux aussi revenir sur ce que j'ai
dit du coup il ya c'était vendredi j'ai
eu quand je suis venu la raison pour
laquelle j'ai posté cette vidéo et/ou
que les fêtes ou quoi c'était pas pour
combattre les précèdent de l'homophobie
comme je l'avais dit c'était pas vrai
la vérité c'est que c'est une bêtise je
les fais donc sciemment cette bêtise je
savais que je savais le danger auquel je
pouvais m'exposer ou quoi
aujourd'hui maintenant trois jours après
trois quatre jours après avec les
réactions qui sont suivis avec donc plus
qu'a dit choqué autant et quand je suis
venu sur le plateau et que j'ai vu les
gens avec leurs propres cartes pour le
mode qui pourrait pourrir et fauqué qui
est ok qui est pas ok pour le
déferlement de haine avec benjamin
pour moi ça va bien à dire qui est ok et
qui n'est pas ok avec le fait qu'on
parce que le déferlement de haine ça se
traduit par là la mort qu'on attend de
moi c'est le fait qu'il y ait des gens
qui viennent chez mes parents le fait
qu'ils aient des gens qui me suivent
dans la rue le fait qu'ils les gens qui
veulent me suis donc laissé à croquer
comme vous l'avez jamais vu ça c'est un
truc 100% être ok et avoir défendu son
ok comme vous l'avez fait vous c'est
défendre le fait que oui on doit tuer
quelqu'un dans la nature peut nous faire
la morale non plus quand même
plus
on en parlera baptistin deux minutes là
pour l'instant laisse finir allez-y
je pouvais passer à une autre question
daniel daniel daniel daniel a été
extrêmement choquée que de ce qu'elle a
vu et c'est vrai que je la voyais elle
était extrêmement ému quand vous lui
avez parlé vendredi mais sûre qu'est ce
que vous avez à répondre non mais je
crois qu'on a tous commencé nos propos
en disant qu' évidemment on condamner
complètement la violence bien sûr ça va
ça va tellement de soi moi j'ai eu hier
hier quand on a reparlé j'ai commencé
tout de suite en disant que je pensais
surtout à vos parents est ce que
justement je savais que ça allait à sa
veste était arrivé et ça me fait une
peine incroyable et je trouve tellement
que le jeu n'en vaut pas la chandelle et
je n'arrive pas depuis vendredi à vous
cernez je n'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi vous faites ça vous savez en
plus c'est pas la première fois qu'il ya
eu des menaces et des choses qui prêtait
à un message il doit être audible il
doit être compréhensible tout de suite
la personne je crois n'a compris votre
message vos parents sont en danger et on
al'impression vous vous enfoncez va
pas vous répondre benjamin roure oui le
message c'est à dire cette vidéo
justement j'ai voulu en faire naître un
an créer un mur n'avait pas et moi on
m'a dit tu peux pas apparaître crédible
et venir sur un plateau et dire mépris
des passagers d'adp intervideo tu peux
pas tu peux pas faire ça donc j'en écris
un j'ai dit que c'était pour combattre
l'homophobie
non là c'est didot il n'a pas mais le
message qu'il faut trouver maintenant
c'est trois jours après accor a posté
cette vidéo vous je dis que j'ai à comme
à tchernobyl où quoi où je dors dans une
église les réactions qui a eu ce que les
gens on en penser ce que ma vie
aujourd'hui ce qu'elles vont devenir ces
camps votre vie aujourd'hui
j'en ai plus aujourd'hui plus de vie je
n'ai plus de vie c'est à dire je ne peux
plus sortir de chez moi je peux plus
recommander de couches chez moi parce
que l'ivoire me reconnais je peux juger
plus de famille j'ai plus d'amis j'ai
plus rien mais c'est pas grave je suis
pas ici pour faire la différence
mais c'est grave j'ai tout de suite une
question excusez moi mais pourquoi vous
refais là il ya deux jours cette vidéo
qui remet de l'huile sur le feu suivront
ces juges avaient j'essaye de vous
suivre de pur bon sens à donner à des
manières alors j'ai d'insurrection voilà
je savais que ça n'allait pas du tout
est de mon côté ça n'allait pas du tout
apaiser la haine je le savais non parce
que la première fois
que vous ne mesurez y est parce que ça
allait mais daniel comme appât
mais aujourd'hui selon divers batista
youtuber identitaire et catholique déjà
quand vous avez réagi que vous avez vu
la première vidéo j'ai reçu des
centaines de fois en fait oui alors il
ya plusieurs choses alors pour répondre
d'abord à votre question il faut
comprendre parce que c'est vrai que pour
certains on peut avoir du mal à cerner
en disant peut-être cesser qui réunit
enfin c'est qu'une danse il fait avec
une danse c'est pas grave etc oui oui
toi quand tu danses chez toi ou la
boulange de quoi perso je m'en fous tu
vois c'est ce que tu veux ce que tu
comprends pas c'est qu'une église pour
des chrétiens c'est un lieu sacré ça
veut dire que pour nous ça nous peine
moi c'est de la peine que j'ai reçu ça
me fait du mal de voir ça franchement
c'est comme si j'allais nantes et toi
c'est comme si j'allais dans un lieu que
j'allais chez pas dans ta chambre
d'enfants sous sur la tombe d'un de tes
proches etc et que je fais c'est comme
ça
alors si ça a été dans une agonie sur
une mosquée ça m'aurait plus mis en
colère pour le coup parce que ça mange
moins peiné puisque forcément c'est
moins sacré pour moi mais maintenant
j'aurais trouvé ça dégueulasse tout
autant là pour le coup c'est plus la
peine qui prend le dessus parce que
voilà c'est quelque chose qui nous est
chère qui est sacré et en fait tu
t'attaques directement à nous et en plus
on se sent impuissant parce qu'on peut
rien faire pour te répondre parce
qu'évidemment tu t'entoures d'une armée
d'avocats on me fait toujours très
attention à ce qu'on a dit en lisant
faut pas que ça donne dans la menace
faut pas que sa tendance à mais en fait
ça là il ya la colère qu'il a mais par
contre quand vous disiez tout à l'heure
où il ya beaucoup de gens qui demandent
pourquoi t'as fait ça je comprends pas
pourquoi tu as fait ça mais toi tu lui
ai répondu tout seul sur twitter tu l'as
bien dit j'ai fait mon petit buzz sûreté
pmp et ma petite victime pour être
protégé de toute façon les cathos n'ont
rien dans le slip mdrrr ya rien à
craindre j'ai tout gagné d'inconnus a
star en l'amour tu as aussi dit je chie
sur l'islam et le christianisme c'est le
problème des lots togo tommies et s'ils
sont offusqués c'est parce qu'ils savent
bien au fond que c'est des conneries
leur religion 6 guerre il y avait des
airs passionnante et si oui c'est facile
non non j'ai été faire vérifier regarder
ton content qu'il soit bonne pour eux
parce que je savais que tu allais dire
ça j'ai quand même des justin
christianophobes c'est clair et net
alors là je suis content je suis content
que tu reviennes sur le fait que tu
dises que c'était pas pour défendre
contre l'homophobie et s'est passé mais
c'est bien ça tu vois tu
j'ai même pas besoin de le dire que tu
es un menteur donc la daf wata monty
cette fois ci tu roman non je comprends
tu es jeune tu es un gamin tu veux faire
le buzz tu te tu t'exposes alors un tien
dire monsieur tu vends des photos toi
nue sur internet et tout et je pense
qu'un jour tout ça c'est tu vas te
rendre compte que tu être que tu as fait
une connerie là tu dis j'ai plus dit
donc déjà tu vois ta en compte moi ça me
fait de la peine pour toi et en tant que
catholique bien sûr j'ai de la colère
car je pourrais très bien de dire
en fait ton temps que non mais ça donne
catholique j'ai envie de prier surtout
pour que pour ça ça conversion et pour
surtout pour que peut-être ils se
rendent compte à mon avis c'est pas à
nous de faire ça je pense que il ya
beaucoup de français qui pensent qu'en
fait il ya juste ton père qui devrait
être mettre une tarte et te dire arrête
de dandiner et va travailler parce qu'en
gros c'est ça là on est en train de
parler et des millions de français sont
en train de parler d'un truc en fait
c'est une connerie de gamins qui est qui
et qui acariens en service a pris ça
mais maintenant il faut que ça abîme est
maintenant là on est en train d'inverser
le trident dans le pot cindy tim hill et
larmoyant et c'est la christianophobie
c'est un fait assure avéré c'est même la
première religion attaqué en france les
9700 acte christianophobes 500 églises
qui ont été et modem mais cimetière qui
ont été profanées 250 agressions anti
chrétiens en france c'est plus que
n'importe quelle autre religion c'est
pas un concours évidemment puisque les
crayons sont plus représentés mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il ya quand
on dit oui quand il dit vous quand vous
validez le hockey etc celle-ci validé
choses mais on pourrait faire la moue la
même rapprochement avec 110 ans quand
vous validez ça c'est aussi un pas
envers ensuite on va casser des crucifix
puis ensuite on va attaquer des églises
etc en avoir et non mais tu ne dis pas
ça c'est ça autant rien à voir que quand
eux ils disent ok que tu dises et puis
ramenée à ma mort ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on peut faire la même illégale
et sa compagne elle doit faire la même
désolation donc là c'est déjà de la
profanation il faut que tu le comprends
ça c'est déjà mais c'est pas tout ça
mais dans le mot profanation tu
vérifiera l'étymologie c'en est déjà
donc c'est grave pour nous il faut que
tu comprennes géraldine maillet moi
j'étais pas là vendredi j'ai regardé
attentivement mes camarades et je vous
ai écoutés alors vous avez exactement
l'âge de machines et effectivement si ma
fille les sages avec c'est une petite
conne et je pense que j'ai vraiment
j'essaierai d'en remettre sur le droit
chemin la sq effectivement je trouve
mais attendait parce qu'après je suis
plus aimable avec vous l'espère parce
que je sais pas si c'est une question
d'éducation de déviance auvray perdu
mais vous êtes le porte parole de
personnes à part peut-être de votre de
votre perdition et vous êtes finalement
le sam homme de l'époque je trouve moi
mais après j'ai été mais hyper choqué
c'est à dire qu'on avait mis là et
maintenant on à benjamin et on trouve ça
normal et en fait on trouve ça normal de
dire oui enfin oui mais en même temps
enfin c'est choquant mais en même temps
il faut pas le menacé de mort c'est pas
bien ce que vous avez fait je n'avais
mais en même temps le ce en même temps
ce n'est pas d'huile sur le feu ce c'est
pas possible c'est insupportable parce
qu'on jette en pâture et en fait on mois
pour moi en fait excuse-moi daniel mais
moi j'étais super choqué parce que moi
je suis croyante aussi comme toi et moi
ces images je m'en fous que ça me choque
pas en fait il faut pas mettre la
religion c'est pas c'est pas sacré c'est
pas au dessus tout la religion c'est la
religion c'est à sphère intime
cette affaire privée tu vas pas aller
dans une église parce qu'il a mis un
crop tort que tu as dis oh là là quelle
horreur il a mis dans un creux octobre
il ya mis un croc topps c'est
dégueulasse non en fait on s'en fout ta
religion c'est un truc privé c'est un
truc intime moi ça n'a pas ébranlé ma
foi ou pas ma foi donc je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui en faisant ça on s'attend
qu'à à son en s'attaquant à benjamin
finalement on le fragilise et je pense
que ça montre que justement aujourd'hui
notre société elle est pourri parce
qu'on donne justement la parole aux
intégristes à tous les intérêts de
toutes les religions mais après a fait
le jeu mais j'ai tous les morts je suis
désolé de vous le dire mais bien sûr
nous aimerions comme j'aime
bien faire le sont pas du tout est là
c'est vous qui donnez des leçons cattier
qu'en disant votre religion elle doit
être intérieur et c'est à nous à
l'église est sacré le christ lui-même
dans l'évangile a chassé les marchands
du temple avec des cordes quand ils
profane est le temple donc c'est un
aussi le devoir des chrétiens de
défendre les églises qui est un lieu
sacré qui est la maison de dieu après je
dis pas que là ça doit rentrer dans le
débat c'est juste une petite aparté que
j'ai fait un nom doit être proportionnée
et attention mais la vérité c'est que
oui aujourd'hui je mentais un homme
n'est plus un enfant parce que là tout
le monde dit le gamin le gamin mépris
était un homme donc à un moment en fait
moi si un catholique à l'aide dans un
club gay ou quelque chose comme ça avec
un crucifix une tenue de templiers pour
faire la morale à tout le monde et qui
s'en prenaient une je ne défendrai pas
voyez parce qu'à un moment je pense que
oui qu'en fait quand il faut prendre
soin d'éviter quand on est dans la
provocation pure qui s'avère provoqué
provoquer c'est bien pour avoir une
réaction on peut pas provoquer et
ensuite demander il faut qu' aucune
réaction et non halal et mena
alors pas la mort non pas une claque
dans la gueule c'est pas la mort
il faut pas
il faut
viser les choses il faut aussi rare chez
les choses peut-être que s'il avait pris
plus de claques dans la gueule quand il
était plus jeune peut-être
je suis désolé at his bâtisse que le
laxisme 3,10 du lac saint jean
vous rendez compte de la alors on est
tous d'accord pour dire qu'il a fait une
énorme connerie ici franchement c'est
vrai que voilà samoa samoa tout cas ça
va choquer leurs épargnes et où je le
dis voilà il sort était dans une célèbre
dans une mosquée j'aurais été choqué
vraiment de voilà doigt ce que aussi je
lui ai déjà dit ici j'ai beaucoup de mal
à voilà je trouve qu'il faut respecter
les religions il faut respecter donc on
le tue mais voilà
ça va finir laissez moi finir s'il vous
plaît mais baptiste aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui benjamin benjamin il a signé
sa vie est un enfer et c'est vrai qu'on
ne peut pas cautionner les menaces de
mort qu'il reçoit oui mais cette demande
a sa méthode ne
pas sortir dans la rue mais il peut pas
il peut même pas commander chez lui sa
maman il ya ce que j'en ai entendu en
pleurs elle fait énormément de peines
cyril vous savez pourquoi moi je peux
sortir dans la rue sans votre management
parce que je vous provoque personnes en
fait parce que je suis respectueux tout
simplement aussi qu'on étudie les
conséquences mais les conséquences ne
sont pas justifiées oui on peut dire
tout cela ici faire de la démagogie en
disant c'est pas bien c'est pas bien oui
ça changera rien en attendant le point
qui a fait basculer les choses c'est ses
actes à lui la responsabilité c'est la
sienne faut arrêter de rejeter les trucs
sur les amerrissages et c'est alors dans
le sable il y en a ici qui
réagissent mal visons pour agir de la
même façon mais lui tel ne sera que
assumer les actes ça voudrait dire
accepter qu'on tape dessus lui même
mettre à genoux et me mettre comme ça et
vas-y fais moi payer ce que j'ai fait à
tes yeux et qui était mauvais moi je
pense pas comme ça j'assume mes actes en
venant ici en m'exprimant et en filles
ont un champ d'études ihs justement
tu sais très bien que ça va être
maintenant qu' à la déferlante
médiatique et pour arriver tu es dans
une bulle le premier qui attendra les
mêmes attentes et là moi je sais que
c'est bidon je veux dire on le sait tous
donc je veux dire était protégé par
satisfaire de ce faire deux sphères de
victimisation mais c'est un pas normal
je suis un benjamin j'aimerais que
benjamin répondent non j'épuré n'avait
pas alors mathieu évidemment je ne
cautionne pas du tout les menottes
demeure surtout pas comme je ne
cautionne pas non plus par don de
baptistes nient vous qui dites flumet
des mannala il a pas reçus à cette tarte
ou monsieur qu'on a vu passer d'eau qui
dit il faut le frapper tout ça c'est que
ce n'est pas aux revanches là où je me
perds totalement avec benjamin c'est que
la première fois que vous êtes venus
c'était il y avait soit disant un acte
un peu un peu militant alors qu'ils
étaient très maladroit fait par un gamin
de 18 ans et ça choquait des catholiques
je sais pas répond non plus bénins mais
voilà ils habitent et maintenant vous
arrivez vous dit il n'y avait pas du
tout de messages en fait donc 1 il n'y a
pas de messages et de vous recommencez
donc là évidemment je me jette des
directives mans c'est de la provocation
pure et dure et que la maintenance jeu
mais de l'autre côté parce que je ne
comprends plus du tout on a jamais c'est
bien ça s'il n'y a pas de message contre
les cyber dissidents mais il n'y a pas
de message mais
après quand on voit les messages aux
mauves pas même sur les réseaux enfin
quand on voit le me faut bien quel point
les présents plus que jamais partout sur
les réseaux là comme la haine comme
plein de choses là moi je là moi je suis
là et aujourd'hui choisir sa tête passe
à ton message ça n'était pas congeler
filmé et c'est ce que j'ai voulu faire
c'est ce qu'on va te dit ce pire
alors j'avais vécu des trucs mais
j'aurais jamais comme une sitcom ça
c'est hyper bouillon j'ai déjà fait des
vidéos je disais je ne cautionne pas les
blagues racistes je ne cautionne pas les
vagues sur l'évolution j'aurais jamais
communiquer pour combattre à combattre à
combattre une cause qui est la mienne
qui est le mot funky et l'homophobie
j'ai vécu toute ma vie je serai jamais
dans une église pour pouvoir préparer
ses bouillons et ça fait ça fait 18 ans
et ça fait irrespectueux pour
communiquer pour combattre les causes je
leur ai pas dit comme ça mais maintenant
au journal avec sa maison mais de là
comme ça comme ça donc j'ai fait ça pour
s'amuser en gros si c'est pour m'amuser
de
l'avis de lescure s'est passé par ironie
c'est vrai j'ai fait le lendemain
lendemain de la vidéo mais est-ce que tu
comprends que des gens sont blessés ou
même pas parce qu'on n'entend jamais
là-dessus moi je suis obligé de dire et
je le crois je pense mais je suis obligé
de prendre le pas de dire il faut pas
que menacer de mort c'est à et d'essayer
un minimum de mettre ta ta place en me
disant c'est un gamin il vit même si
c'est censé être un adulte c'est
visiblement là où tout fonctionne pas
correctement donc soit un petit point du
genre mais toi j'ai l'impression que
jamais à un seul moment tu te mets à la
place d'un croyant qui en fait ne peut
rien faire et de l'autre compter son
écran n'a jamais fait de messages
homophobes rien du tout et en fait on
lui crache à la gueule ce qu il ne peut
rien statu quo même embarras une dp
blesser les gens je l'avais déjà dit
comprendre pourquoi tu t'excuses
ironiquement pourquoi t'as pas s'agir
des vraies excuses
je suis désolé ironie
moi ce que je dis un truc je trouve ça
un peu c'est exactement ce que vous avez
dit juste avant
j'arrive difficilement à concevoir qu'on
puisse être blessé parce que moi j'ai
dansé dans une église je mangeais 18 ans
enfin continuer votre vie allez allez
allez prier dans votre église et
continuer à croire en ce que vous croyez
jeu c'est génial et c'est hyper bien
défendre et le comme vous le défendez
vous négligez fait de la merde enfin
franchement
m6 avait agi liz may fois le problème
c'est que mais en fait c'est toujours la
même chose c'est comme si j'allais sur
la tombe d'un de vos proches que je
dansais dessus je faisais du toit et que
quand vous me disais que ça vous plaît
ça fragilise pas votre deuil et bien sûr
un four ça vous ferait du mal c'est
évident c'est un lieu sacré pour nous
c'est un
excellent exemple de baptiste et
testés pour la demande et des collages
écoute chez papa je pas convaincu assez
bas mais après je comprends que vous
pensez vous leurs sentiers pas parce que
évidemment c'est un truc de croire que
je dois t'y gendre à bâtir du projet
bâti je comprends tout à fait ce que tu
as ressenti et ce qu'ont ressenti des
milliers de gens maintenant et je suis
tu nous as dit tout à l'heure c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas lui la victime c'est
des milliers de gens qui sont sentis
offensés mais aujourd'hui benjamin moi
ça me fait quand même de la peine
d'avoir comme ça de le voir je sens que
là il est autant vendredi je te sentais
encore voilà encore là aujourd'hui je
sens que tu as été au bout du rouleau t
étais et je sais plus quoi faire
justement dire du coup sûr vidéo parce
que c'est sûr que l'âge du christ est un
peu brouillon la deuxième si je les fait
essayer de les poster la deuxième la 12e
à la deuxième vidéo des excuses c'est ce
que tu on attend de moi que je m'excuse
tout le monde est excusé tout le monde
ya pas y'a pas une personne qui me dit
de ne pas le faire enfin pas et vous
tombez d'excusés et je les fait comme ça
parce que pour moi c'était un peu un
hymne à la liberté alors ça peut faire
un peu cliché où c'est que je dise à
l'épreuve du fait de cette façon là mais
cette vidéo l'aller j'ai le droit de la
faire et je demande pas de mes avocats
d'être à côté de ma pour le dire mais ça
je le rappelle moi même parce que je le
sais et moi aussi j'ai un peu étudiant
en droit j'arrêtais au bout de trois
mois et je les comprends l'année
prochaine mais je suis attaché à ce
droit là et je suis passionné par sa et
et
moi moi c'est les excuses elle passait
par là par la légèreté par mois c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a envie que ce soit
pas ton avenir aujourd'hui tu as 18 ans
tanvir sur quoi ton avenir
je sais pas c'est bah c'est pas chez ba
non mais tu en es ce que tu regrettes tu
es ce que tu es ce que si aujourd'hui
non je quatre pages ne l'a pas battue
referait la même vidéo si tu savais tout
ce qui se passait derrière theuriau
ferait la même vidéo vraiment viser une
question moi c'est à dire que la nature
autant on te dit voilà il va se passer
tout ça derrière tu referait la même
vidéo n'a aucun regret c'est parce que
j'ai peur j'ai toutes les choses que
j'ai faites quand j'ai vu toutes les
choses que j'ai faites donc la peine les
gens s'en remet dans la semaine c'est
pas parce que tu as peur mais rien n'y
fait parce que il ya plein de choses qui
sont que des gens face à un acte que
j'ai le droit de faire nommer malin et
si on te dit pas ce que ça a blessé des
gens je le referais
sa sagesse a jamais été mon intention
[Musique]
face à ses importantes je le referai pas
me ferait passer peut-être que comme
socialement mais
parce qu'il veut pas dire qu'il a peur
et c'est sa banque
venir dire que ce serait comme une heure
en arrière et ce serait me soumettre à
toutes les personnes qui veulent que je
m'excuse mais non mais non il ya plein
de personnes qui veulent tu t'excuses
que tu leur as tu les a punis ils sont
lents a fait de la peine c'est yes house
en mai
bien ici
génère qui sont composés tendres mais
est ce que les secours cessent de 2 mg
outre il faut que tu viens est ce que
dans trois jours il va y avoir une
troisième vidéo et bien sûr ou
impossibles n'a pas trouvé moi je
pourrais bien
mais ce que tu es ce que tu vas en faire
une autre ou pas du tout j'ai déjà eu ce
jeu je peux vous dire une chose les
vidéos ne sont pas monétiser aucune
marque même soutien c'est pas question
parce que c'est ce que tu pensais
beaucoup le buzz l'attention il n'y a
aucun retour budgétaire là dessus et
bien sûr que si moi je suis un
influenceur dans les équipes comment ça
fonctionne tu gagnes 400000 aude et math
de dymat ne fait pas ce genre derrière
il va y avoir aucun retour truskel et
vouliez d'été personnes extrêmement
connue - ya trois jours on parle de toi
déjà moi ce que ça me fâche coup on juge
ce qui fait dans sa vie voilà cisma poil
sur les réseaux on n'a pas le juger on
n'a pas à le mentionner déjà première
veut bien exactement ensuite moi je
pense que je préfère voir un personnage
comme ça qui fait de la merde comme j'ai
dit tu es un petit con mais je préfère
voir ça plutôt que qu'est ce que tu
penses de charlie hebdo par exemple de
charlie hebdo daniel qu'est ce tu penses
de charles ix ème de la bouche bée
personnellement je vais te dire ce que
j'en pense moi rapport moi je suis
contre l'asm d'accord moi je suis contre
mais je sais là c'est légal donc je me
tais ils ont droit de faire leur truc
oui mesdames blesse évidemment je suis
contente de le voir d'accord mais je
vous vois pas sur des plateaux en train
de dire ouais mais là ça me dérange car
l'aide de la main par l'osce avec les
artistes
qu'est ce que je vais m'arrêter dans une
émission pour parler de charles ix alors
dit moi maintenant ce que tu penses de
charles habas mois à chaque fois ça me
ça m'écoeure on en a parlé parfois ici
il faut que je fais bien en drôle toute
la hauteur de provocation moi moi moi
j'aimerais savoir ce qu'ils pensent de
charlie hebdo moi j'ai un petit problème
mais pour moi le droit de cet
acharnement sur cette personne on lui
pourrit sa vie parce qu'il a fait une
connerie il a levé la jambe dans une
église
du
studio que tu dirais cela laisse le mot
de la fin que tu dirais
moi le mot de la fin est d'âge puisque
jadis qui n'a pas envie de tête adressé
à toutes les personnes visées ces
laissez nous parler ou est ce que c'est
un hebdo c'est ce que nos mères semaine
un numéro laissé
merci le par là je m'adresse pas aux
personnes qui avaient retenu que j'étais
blessé je m'adresse pas elle n'a pas le
choix mais
le message que je veux faire la queue je
faire passer l'armé à un petit peu qui
est important à mes yeux c'est que je
mandat qu'on puisse protéger mes parents
ça serait bien ce qui n'est toujours pas
capable d'allaiter et j'ai envoie des
lettres j'affiche le pas et coups de fil
la sûreté de mes parts on n'est toujours
pas assurée alors que l'adresse est
partout et privée des gens y vont tout
le temps donc j'aimerais que cela puisse
être fait qu'en sa fin au plus vite quoi
j'ai à m'aimer et mes amis se font
tabasser aussi à mes amis se font
tabasser
non ça c'est inadmissible même bâtisse
et
usages de la phase aller on souffle on
s'en fout vous allez faire quoi là ces
prochains jours
je pense que je vais écrire parce que je
vais oublier tout ce qui est tout ce que
je suis en train de vivre actuellement
et je m'en rappeler mais ce que je vais
faire c'est survivre le vêtement ou
franchement j'ai survivre